Hollywood has a tendency to get a little
too predictable when it comes to
depicting heroes like yourself and the
world around these dudes so I'm going to
run through a list of cliches and if you
don't mind I just want you to raise your
hand if you've been asked to depict one
or more of these well-worn
tropes of Hollywood having to go
shirtless all right okay having to wear
a wife-beater shirt yeah I don't know if
that's the correct word anymore I think
it's not a tango or something I think
it's still a white bearded man Rocky
we call them tank tops tank tank tops
tank tops
all right sporting stubble and always
looking sweaty it's really hot in
Toronto right now all right uh having a
traumatic backstory like a dead wife or
a child
listen this is my favorite one walking
away from a fiery wreckage every week
I'm trying to catch up making a smartass
quip right at the moment you kill
someone and last but not least most more
like having to kill someone again after
you thought they were dead yes that ends
that mix exercise alright alright so
this is nothing a little curious about
you know many action adventures require
the heroes to run but not everybody can
make it look so effortless I mean I know
when I run I look like a girl I run like
a girl
so have I know it seems a little little
micro you know production but have you
ever received coaching so you don't run
like a kid or even look like Napoleon
Dynamite when you run yeah I don't do
any of my own running I don't think
anybody here would admit that I just I
just I was just doing some running the
other day on set and it's my thing doing
right Vikings for four years so this is
a bit of a new job for me and I've never
had to figure out running after cars and
bad guys and stuff especially at
nighttime and I realized that they had
this this car rigged with a camera and
I'm going make me catch up with you
don't wait for me I'm thinking that was
a good idea so I could just run
hell-for-leather and make it look as
real as possible and then we did like
six or seven takes and then I watched
the playback and I just kept thinking
why does Tom Cruise look so good when he
runs it's cuz he holds something back
I'm running I'm going
and then I'm just I'm just praying that
they don't put it into slow-mo yeah you
got to leave it all out on the line and
like I remember the first time I had to
run on camera I was just so like trying
to be just in it and doing exactly that
and I ran past the camera and I was just
like and everybody was like but what are
you doing wrong just like you know oh
it's a lot Dominic I view our Eric have
you run well no I I'll stick with I I
don't do any of my own running Donna how
much we're sounding really pathetic like
it's difficult yeah we have a really
hard time running it right pretty hard
part of our job yeah but it is when you
spend the whole day running though you
want to fire the camera department cuz
usually you've done like six 100 meter
sprints and then they go we do another
one because it was out of focus
yeah already all right
so a TW we have a favorite feature we
call this a watch this sorry about that
we all know the great work they do now
but now what I'd like to ask you is to
go back in your early career and think
about those roles that you you know
you'd rather forget that maybe you want
to go so far as apologize for
I'm gonna start with Theo Wow Wow I've
done some terrible stuff in the
beginning not just as an actor as a
human no um hi I guess you know the
glaring one on it the second you said it
it hit me but was an Olsen twin movie I
did it was called the challenge um
but as a young actor I got to go out to
uh I think I was like 26 playing 16 I
don't know why that just keeps happening
but um and I was in uh I don't know
somewhere in Mexico for a couple months
but I gotta tell you I actually kind of
enjoyed it so I don't know if I feel so
bad about it but y'all stick with the
Olsen twin movie the challenge okay
uh-huh
Eric all right I'm gonna go Cooper cuz
you looked up cuz I feel like you got
something I look good
yeah pretty much everything before 2003
I'm upset about
there's not one it's my career's
littered with things I need to apologize
for but I would say watch the last ship
I'm proud of that but you gotta throw us
one but my first job was um cut a condom
advert I got chased down the road by
30,000 Czechoslovakian sperms still one
of my better pieces of work that's quite
good at it's quite good commercial uh on
the show real skin on the show right
yeah up front
yeah I'd I think I ended up in the
condom as well there's a huge condom it
made no sense this commercial I was
being chased by so it did not occur
still don't really understand it oh no I
don't think it improved the cells of
condoms
it doesn't make sense to me either miss
oh wow
Eric you didn't do one did a condom
commercial no no not a conifer uh uh uh
something you'd like to maybe forget her
everything well like I said everything
before 2003 but I did do the first job I
ever had was an episode of a show called
Saved by the Bell
and I loved that show I was the evil
volleyball player there was a good guy
and I was the bad guy and I remember
yelling I didn't like it take it was my
first job I yelled cut that's not gonna
work
we got to do this over again the
director I swear to God was wearing an
ascot told me to the side and said I'm
the only person on this set that yells
cut out I want to hear you ever say
y'all cut again I was like listen dude I
just wanted to do it again I'm sorry the
microphone
it'll get literally the guy had the the
big you know the cone thing and uh and
it was it was it was terrifying looking
back at it and you know it was Saved by
the Bell but then so am I here to
verbally apologize for it you want me to
apologize for it like is a confessional
I am sorry for that I will never do it
again
well well let's ask the crowd Theo
graciously actually found a picture need
a camera close by that we can where's
the camera we can focus on this picture
of him from Saved by the Bell is that me
isn't it do do that again Thank You
Leone for this I want to let you see
it's that good just believe me it's
great googling it fantastic my peach oh
yeah who's a pastel as wearing a pastel
tank top sorry oh it's it's over there
what happened
alright how about you Clive what about
you you got something actually the first
thing that came to mind was when you
come out of drama school you hear all
these stories when you can I see the DVD
extras and people promoting shows and I
like when comas brown or calls you don't
sue no that never happened to me I was
like auditioning for take whatever I
could get and when I came out drama
school I did I did a film called heroes
and villains which actually was um with
James Corden was in with me as well I'm
sure he'd be just as embarrassed about
it
yeah it had nothing to do with heroes
and villains it was about the honey trap
and trying to catch people cheating on
their wives and things I played this
male gigolo
it was awful I had to play tennis and I
was literally playing tennis over to
courts and I hadn't got much camera
technique I still don't have much
chemistry but I host jöhnny they were
firing tennis balls at me and I was
trying to run across two courts and I
didn't realize that the country couldn't
kill me followed me all over the two
gods is some awful film and I swear if
anyone wants to look it up just to prove
that I was in it it's still gonna be two
hours of your life you won't get back
right how about you Cory mmm-hmm
oh man I mean thankfully it wasn't on
film I when I came out of drama school
and I had to I work with the Boys and
Girls Club of America and we were doing
a lot of you know going to different
places and we had to put on shows and
unfortunately I was blessed with the bug
musical show so I had to wear this like
but but it was weird because I had like
this blue dinosaur costume I mean like
it was like it was really embarrassing
but it was inspiring to the kids because
I was up there with like you know twelve
year old and all that crazy stuff so it
was fun um but I would say I might have
to apologize
for the Georgia heat and he's hair on
rocket I might have to apologize for
foot foot for the craziness thing that
goes on with the with the lace front rig
um but other than that I would say watch
24 legacy right after the Superbowl
all right Josh how about you oh there's
a few but uh I'd say one of the most
embarrassing was a was a saber tooth
whoo that was fantastic fantastic uh you
know I play like the camp counselor guy
you know and then there's a experiment
gone wrong genetic experiment they
create this saber-toothed tiger you know
wait and I'm up there in the mountains
and I remember I had this fight and I
have to do this martial arts kick in the
beginning and I thought I was so cool
you know training for it and then I saw
the movie and I I'm doing some little
[ __ ] dance
yeah like before I go in the camera I'm
just going boo boo back back I just look
like an idiot like I'm jumping on a
trampoline as' bouncing all over the
place and then when the tiger jumps out
you know this is first-gen like computer
animation stuff and I was sitting with
my entire family you know back in
Georgia
my niece isn't everything around 14
people and the tiger jumps out in the
whole room burst in the laughter
cuz it was it was like a different color
than the fake Paul they had on a stick
you know oh I got you and uh and it
looked like Tony the Tiger you know from
the cereal so I was like well I guess
laughter is a good thing we vow that's
it's supposed to scare everybody when
the tiger jumped out it was fantastic
Dominic how about you well I mean yeah
I've got some rific [ __ ] as well I think
um my first co-ed drama school I do the
thing cold I'm not sure if you remember
Beastmaster yeah yeah I played Captain
Cove and I was disgusted the second I
walked on so I think was the first time
I actually blow up at a director and so
I've been really gateless and then I
guess the next one was probably the
second installment of Neuros place which
I was forced into by Fox who made me do
it
all right like three months all right
think back to when your kids your big TV
watchers you're born and raised on
television give me your childhood TV
crush that Meredith baxter-birney in
your life or something that maybe she's
a little too old for you you know I'm
talking about when you watch TV who was
that
who's the chick that just made you smile
Theo no me yeah it's so funny while you
were saying that I got taken back to the
place of what I was thinking of it was
uh it was easy its it always comes up
Alyssa Milano who's the boss
she had a workout video she had this
workout video who's kind of haha
right about the time I figured out it
was I was I was a man Clive how about
you oh I did I went really young though
when you said yeah I was thinking rose
really when when did something happen I
didn't quite understand what was
happening first person it has to be
thing I thought not person oh my god
that's happening Cheetara
Thundercats
but to be fair I find this panel the
most ridiculous thing for me because my
wife has an unhealthy crush on Eric Dane
and Josh Holloway and now I'm sitting
here on a panel with them both I'm not
sure if I'm gonna start a fight with him
or ask them to join a threesome wasn't
what happens on the panel Oh
all right Cory how about you Oh probably
they watch it would have to be pam pam
and yeah i mean that was that was like
my crush I mean I I just I just
remembered a theme music what come on
it's just glued to TV like look oh but
uh
in another pan Pam Grier yeah like she
was she was just grew up watching her
and I was like yeah it's co-ed like six
year old Eric hi I'm married my crush I
actually I did well my first crush when
I was a little kid was Tabitha and
bewitched I think she was the was she
the daughter of the dad she's the
wiggler knows and that did it for me
um it wasn't Kelly from safe with Abell
you know by that time I already had a
crush on my now wife so I doubt I guess
not a very interesting answer but that's
very nice married 12 years this year I'm
very proud of
alright Dominic what about you what did
you watch Oh totally in love with them
Ferris Bueller's girlfriend yeah giving
Cameron mouth-to-mouth resuscitation
after falling into the pool he wasn't
unconscious he was just pretending she
was gorgeous I'm remembering stop it
did I give too much away yeah that's
good not as much as heated so now that's
my mm-hmm all right Josh mine strangely
enough was and it ruined me because from
then on that's what I sought to date and
that's what I married it was the dancing
girls from Fantasy Island every time
every time mr. Rourke would go and they
and they'd start their dance at the
beginning I was like island girls are
for me and and I married one Hey
yeah my wife's from Jakarta I'm from
Indonesia
thanks mr. Worf
thanks a lot mr. Roark I appreciate that
that's good
all right Dominic but lean to the
microphone Tomic you're a low talker so
we want to get it all oh hi um I'm bout
to get hmm childhood crush who was
childhood crush was her name I don't
know but didn't have one it's a child
remember okay
but Pam Alison was certainly got my
attention when I started noticing things
yeah
I started noticing thing alright I want
to jet to something a little superficial
you all have to at one time another had
to get jacked for a roll would any of
you cop to what your most embarrassing
diet routine was tried something
probably won't do that again do for sure
yeah
oh god it was like season three or
something the sons when we were on this
rooftop and juice gets like shanked and
it's a prison term if everybody wants to
know what that means
um and you know was somewhere I was
shirtless and I was going to try this
like this tea that that uh makes you go
to the bathroom like you know really go
and it was a bad idea
in every aspect because the bathroom was
all we were on this prison in LA in the
bathrooms like all the way downstairs in
this porta potty had to run like seven
steps and literally in the middle of it
take I was like I have to go I gotta go
Daniel
and I don't I don't drink that tea
anymore nobody should drink that taste
it's called like it's called like go to
the bathroom violently
don't drink it doesn't work don't all
right Clyde what about you um well I
remember at the end of the end of season
two in Vikings my character Rolo gets
because trampled on by horses so I kind
of I actually thought that was going to
be the very last time I to worry about
what IX I was investing and I ten Ranta
at the end of the end of the season I
was like this is it one because I knew
that Roller wasn't going to die and I
was coming back for season three but I
thought a city's gonna have broken legs
he's not gonna be the warrior he used to
be and it really invested me in this big
fat warrior and he's like sweaty beat
trying to get off and I was eating the
kids chicken nuggets after I had my
dinner I was healing I was just really
invested in that about two weeks before
we came back with season three when the
script started to come through it was
like Rolo is completely healed and these
rides on the battlefield smashing things
down and then I'd really had to make an
effort to get down the gym and start
running and so I was like if you see
that seen them Fox as it Foxcatcher with
Channing Tatum or eats all of the food
and zillion it that he sent me on that
bike and this is sweating so I had like
two weeks of that just kind of
constantly just kind of you know really
murdering myself by not eating and
trying to lose weight far too quickly
and I never ever ever want to go back
there again Cory got a story not really
cuz I don't like dieting I mean I just
like eating like I mean who does it like
I mean maybe I should start so I don't
have to be the only guy on the panel who
hasn't done a shirtless scene yeah
I mean I had to actually try to do it to
slim down after King Kong to do 24 and
we I was trying to do the pescetarian
thing but I didn't realize you had to
actually eat healthy I would just like
stop eating meat but I would eat pizza
cheese pizza and like you know to me um
but I'm working on it I'm getting there
you know I'm getting there
Eric how about you I know I never I
don't dye it I've never had one I I
don't I don't understand it I mean I
have a hard time keeping weight on so
for me a diet just sounds kind of
torturous hey you two
yeah I don't doubt it yeah non the same
admit it's never really done what
someone tried to make me do a juice diet
once I lasted half a day but in that
half day yeah well you you immediately
have diarrhea
and then you're so you so needs salt
that you start licking your arms and
I've never in my life wanted I think
what you call it they look like chicken
you get one cube so you get the juice
two juices every two hours and then a
cube a gift at the end of the day right
which is vegetable stock I've never
loved something so much in my life
salty vegetable stock after doing the
juicy so no yeah that's crazy
it worked in last long she tried
Josh uh I I let this girl convince me to
take those pills that y'all take
sometimes around period time just weight
off of those other ones that make you
lose blows right they make you lose
bloat but it makes you be like working
crazy or the water pills yeah I already
got a bladder like an 80 year old lady
so I mean I have to pee all the time so
when I ate these things I was like Jesus
how many times can you be so I'm with
you on that I'm not gonna have that tea
no and I'm not gonna take the bill
that's called smooth moves by the way I
just if you see smooth moves at your
local grocer don't ya or the water
Domenic well I can't talk that so next
question how do you say next question
all right all right we're going to take
your questions by the way so feel free
to line up I would love to hear from you
just a couple more and then we'll go to
the crowd I want to ask about your most
Awkward fan encounter I have to imagine
that while fans can be great sometimes
it can be a little uncomfortable talking
to them I'm going to start with you Eric
yeah I've ever had a an awkward fan
encounter Manny yes I had one about an
hour ago no I I was at the Indianapolis
500 one year and and I was I lost I got
lost I was with a group and you know we
walked we had security and we were all
Patrick and I were tightly kind of in
this sort of moving sort of human shield
walking through 350,000 people and I
stopped to smell the roses and the next
thing I knew everybody was gone so I'm
kind of looking around going okay nobody
will notice me if I just put my head
down and walk and then this woman
screams at the top of her lungs and the
next thing I know she has me in this
death clutch
but I'm not that close to her because
she's like a Triple D so so um there's a
there's a fair amount of distance
between me and her and she kept
screaming take the picture take the
picture I said honey I'll take the
picture just what you know let's let's
turn whoever I was looking for somebody
to take the picture she didn't have
anybody that she was just screaming out
to anybody who had a phone take a
picture um and I hightailed it out of
there I found my group they thought it
was funny they were actually watching
who I really was about I'd straight
about 15 feet that was it but you know I
lost okay Dominic Purcell this is you
yeah okay uh first year of Prison Break
I was in CBS in Chicago and this lady
was looking at me very weirdly and the
next minute these two police officers
came up to me and said what seems to be
the complaint madam and this is
basically this lady thought that I was
an escaped convict and she'd been
watching she'd been watching Prison
Break and assumed that I was a convict
and the cops came up to me and said they
looked at me and double taped her and
said are you he's an actor he's like no
no no no I've seen it I've seen him I've
seen it that was that was the strangest
event what ever had
fantastic
all right Josh how about you uh yeah I
remember I was just on in Hawaii kind of
off it was a weird location we were
downtown Honolulu and I was just by
myself I think trying to remember
freaking lines or something but I'm just
over on the side and there's some
columns Cement columns around and then
suddenly this older woman slips out from
one of the columns and I mean slips out
like just you know that scary thing in
horror movies where they float like that
she kind of floated up to me and she was
one of those that wear workout gloves
but she's not working out and surprise
60-something which is fine I love that
Kamath uh but she so she floated over to
me and said I've cooked you a meal and
it's just across the street come with me
I didn't go with her
but she said she had a southern meal all
prepared it isn't good that's a little
misery moment oh my god no don't mob me
huh
mr. Cooper about you hmm
I know I have conversations quite what
with a gong quite they're quite lengthy
going for a while and I taught them I
think they're a good big fan and then at
the end of the conversation they go well
you lost your grate in the affair and
then I realized that they think they've
been talking to Dominic West for the
entire conversation and it's happened
about ten times that now I don't say
anything I just take it in and enjoy it
it's happened repeatedly how's yeah I
just kind of confusion not that we've
that alike but I think is this a name
sort of confusion then the finger having
a conversation with that person it's not
that's an outrage
Oh Dominic's art you know you name your
kid Dominic because you know he's gonna
look like another Dominic
all right Clyde what about you I didn't
honestly haven't had any fan encounters
have been too appalling I think but you
show like Vikings then you kind of
expect to kind of get some kind of crazy
people dressed up as Vikings and I love
that I love kind of embracing kind of it
because I think the Vikings ISM
I'll show is it's the first time we've
really done justice to a culture on the
screen so there's a lot of people that
are really excited in Scandinavia and
I've done some Comic Cons and things are
in Scandinavia and I mean the hardest
thing sometimes it's just not offending
somebody
I mean sometimes you'll get you'll be
signing autographs or something and then
Emily Axl dogs fans Latin speaking Latin
or similar and you'll be like how do you
spell that no you play a Viking how do
you not know I just spell my name
yeah you like and then you I was worse
when they've got a picture taken with
you and they wanted sign it and then you
press it cuz I'm Dyslexic as well so I'm
the best of the worst speller the best
of times but then I do I something click
crumble and I hope you're gonna float
away somewhere but no I mean it's great
I mean I'm glad I'm the time of my life
playing Vikings and this is great you
get anyone that kind of comes up and
wants to kind of dress up like your
character or can ever want to interact
with you like that so I kind of them
executing little buzz Corey um I've had
some really cool encounters with a lot
of fans especially The Walking Dead fans
like ever since it was ever since like
joining that it's been it's been kind of
crazy but for me after before Straight
Outta Compton
like when I walk down the street people
don't look at me and go is that Dre like
no one ever did no one does that right
so like now it's it's you know people
will yell like Dre Dre and I'm like
looking around for him I'm like busy and
like yeah and I was at I went home I
think for this past Christmas for break
why I went down south cause all my
family's down south and I was in North
Carolina and we went to like a whoa hey
no fancy I was in we went to a Walmart
as you do and
but Christmas going home with family and
uh and uh you know so we I'm with I'm
with like my cousins and my sister my
uncle and and we walk into the store and
this this this woman comes up and she
goes I know who you are and I was like
hi uh you know and she was like um you
train from Straight Outta Compton I was
like yeah I played him in the movies you
know nice to meet you and everything and
she was like I'm not gonna blow your
spot up I promise and she worked there
by the way so she had the little you
know earphone and everything on and so
she's like I promise you I'm not gonna
blow your Spyder but I just want you to
know I noticed you I was like cool nice
to meet you I literally walked two feet
and I heard her on the radio and she's
like y'all Trey is here
Trey is here this is not a drill this is
not a drill and I'm like oh okay okay so
did so we stopping start walking up the
owl and all the employees start coming
around the corner but it was funny cuz
there was this one lady who like looked
me dead in my face and like looked
around and she was like ten a train like
we're tryin so you know it was just it
was really humbling actually you know to
me cuz I'm a private guy so that's you
know Dominic Cory bring up a good point
have any of the other actors been
mistaken for another male actor besides
Dominic West yeah I was I had a massage
and she had a long time to look me over
like
like an hour and then I got off the
table she said your kid rock right I
said yes I am
yes I am I did a picture with her as ha
ha ha ha does anybody else top that oh
no all right we're gonna go to questions
oh wow Wow
I'm Sarah I want to ask Dominic Cooper
which of Howard Starks inventions would
you like to own um can I have the whole
did I'm Whitney it's which one what I
know
did I made the gun make the entire suit
the Iron Man suit God built that didn't
I
I made that right kill me that yeah did
I make the Iron Man what is going where
are we I think I know the shield just
say something easy say something easy
the shield
it's much
yeah it's made out of vibranium and it's
a hundred percent stronger than any
other metal my question is actually for
Dominic Cooper I'm sorry um I just
wanted to know if you would like to play
Howard Stark again and if you would yeah
yeah yeah absolutely
I love this a really fun if I have so
much fun that we're doing that show with
Hayley Atwell and James we so I hope
this I don't know what they're doing
with it there's been talk of because the
fans seem to have really want petition
to get it back so I fingers crossed yeah
I'd always do it I jump at the chance of
playing him he's great it really yeah I
have excellent fun playing it's very
different from doing the preacher as
well so yeah
you